good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Thursday Thursday that's
right latter half of the week
congratulations hey Jax Jax
how are you I'm good Claudia is there a
reason for your somber tone in asking me
should I see well it's not a somberity
it is a genuine curiosity
thank you I'm doing well thank you
mostly because I know that tonight my
turdy will be less than
I'll be in your arms you will be and
that brings me Comfort Solace joy and
this is our last show of the week so it
feels like the week is you know slowly
winding down we have a very busy day
tomorrow but it will be different than
all other days like why is tomorrow
different from all other tomorrows I
have such a busy 36 hours I am going to
an event tonight then heading straight
to the airport flying to my family
tomorrow there is no show Jack and I
have a busy day and then we're gonna
celebrate Ben's birthday and then it's
Passover it's just like kind of crazy
it's like meetings meetings meetings
birthdays birthdays birthdays
for me today
and today after the show I am sitting
down with Ben software celebrity I kind
of want to give him the I feel like
we've been talking a lot about him
you've been talking a lot of crap
and I'm gonna give him a platform to
offer a rebuttal it'll be our patreon
episode our last one of the month
that'll go up tomorrow so if you're in
desperate need of a Friday episode
you'll have one on patreon and it'll be
a video and audio
kind of
expose if you will
with Ben software celebrity also known
as Bean software celebrity yes it will
be eye-opening I think but I also think
it will be eye-opening in that we might
get some context around some of this
behavior of his you know what's really
going on yeah and maybe we'll I don't
know see him in a different light and be
able to
make sense of some of these things that
he's been doing I don't know what
context could make it okay to leave
unopened can of jar of beans in the
cupboard for a week but you never know
what was going through Ben's mind did
anybody ask how's it Ben doing what's
Ben thinking what was Ben going through
right so amongst other things that will
be a big topic of conversation for you
and Ben obviously him being Ben saw for
celebrity yeah and by the way I do want
to update everyone because I think it's
important to highlight the good when
you're also highlighting the bad this
morning me and Ben are both leaving
tonight for Florida
um at 9am our flight is until 9 00 PM
literally he said he walks into the
bedroom he said you know what maybe I
should pack now so I don't get
overwhelmed later
is he okay I know I was like yes I said
yes that's very good you should pack now
don't get overwhelmed later it's a
little too good it is I mean I packed
yesterday but
my bar like I'm so up here with
preparedness organization you can't
compare to me yeah no that's that's
really good so are we saying that we're
making strides I think some of the
public shame is working the public
vlogging
shame
shame us you know virtually throwing
[__] at him I'm excited for your episode
I'm excited to hear from him also like
Spritz updates Ben updates life updates
yeah it'll be all of that but I do think
we'll spend a good chunk of time giving
him the Florida defend himself yeah
because there's been a lot slung at him
a lot to defend his behavior is
defenseless but sure
it's also his birthday coming up so
maybe a tabula rasa for this New Year
yes tabula rasa
um so it's a great Thursday it's the
latter half of the week we're so close
to the weekend congrats everyone
um we've got a great show for you guys
today
period you mean it how can you be so
certain turd
if you speak it it will be yeah plus
we've never not had a great show
even like there are obviously some that
are better than others but we've never
had a bad show no we've never really had
a bad show we've had a couple like good
shows sometimes after we've been like
podcasting without a day off or a mini
vacation like it gets a little
monotonous yes but it's still a good
show I do think it's a jolly good show I
feel as the purveyor of the stories
today I can say it's going to be a great
show because we have some really
interesting stories today dynamic
dynamic
die Dynamic die Dynamic die dynamic
dynamic dynamic dynamic
Jackie that's beautiful thank you Turtle
Lou
um what did I want to update everyone on
yesterday oh we watched Vanderpump roll
so we do have a TV recap yep not like a
ton to discuss it wasn't no I pushed
myself to stay up for it so that we
could recap it today yeah welcome and it
was in nothing of an episode which I'm
kind of grateful for because I didn't
have the energy to get all fired up so
true like the the like two weeks ago
when we had the car scene like in the
Galaxy lights like I was getting fired
up I had to like parse all my emotions
like comb through the narratives to see
how I truly felt about it but last night
there's there's no hot takes or anything
it was just gearing up for sheena's
wedding and the big Cliffhanger you know
about a scene that we didn't even see
I'm I'm the cliff oh my gosh I'm shook
I'm dangling off of it
so we will do a TV recap of Vanderpump
Rules and we're just gonna have like I
said a jolly good show we shall I think
we should Jump Right In without further
Dilly dallying one thing about me is
like I'm a girl who's up for anything
like I'm down you want a dilly dally
sure you want to dive in let's dive you
want to talk about Arby's you want to
talk about Gyros sure not Arby's like
commenting on our Instagram today what
do they say the thing is and what I love
about our job is like there's so many
toasters in high places like I know that
there is a toaster responsible who just
selected my special for Delta like a lot
of people thought that was like a big
partnership with Delta no literally I
know there's a toaster who's head of
programming and she's like oh this looks
good let me throw Claudia a bone love
you girl send me a message
I have another special coming out soon
um and there are so many toasters who
are social media managers like I'm
pretty like the social media manager
it's a toasty job it's such a toasty job
because it obviously requires like a
wide knowledge of culture social media
you know what's going on in the world so
maybe on today's podcast Instagram
announcement all the social media
managers for the different brands coming
from the brand accounts like I want to
see every single brand that is run by a
toaster yeah well you won't see every
single one because some of them can't
comment it's like not brand safe
Hulu but you'll see a good amount I hope
because we've got friends in high places
medium you know what's so funny about
that song do you know what I'm gonna say
something about Country Strong yes so
it's like this OG classic every country
music fan in the world knows that song
and we're like big country music fans
and I only know that song Because
Leighton Meester covered it in Country
Strong yeah me too because I don't know
other Garth songs really but I know
Baton Rouge and like after Leighton
Meester introduced me to that song then
I you know went down to Garth
you couldn't even because when the movie
came out Garth isn't on Spotify Garth
isn't on iTunes so how were you to go
down a rabbit hole that's why it's the
only Garth song I know right that like
scene where you know Lane Meester is
trying to cover a song on stage but she
gets like stage fright and then Garrett
Headland comes in from the back blame it
all on my roots I showed up in Boots
it's probably one of the greatest
cinematic achievements of our time
not to be dramatic no lies being told it
is good I mean the movie as a whole is
wonderful if you haven't seen it it's
it's part of um required toast
programming it is required programming
that and she's the man and sleepover
because we sleep over all the time there
are some movies that like if you want to
understand this show you have to do your
homework and educate yourself sleepover
really is one of them Country Strong is
another Julie Julie Corky no you guys if
you haven't watched sleepover like I
actually I never say this turn off the
toast go watch sleepover come back and
resume with fresh eyes
literally I'd say another one is morning
glory
agreed
and of course there are the big ones you
know that but we know you've seen them
that's these are the ones Mean Girls
these are the ones that we're worried
you have not seen because they're a
little bit more Niche yeah but they're
so germane to this show and and our
personalities like we would not be the
people that we are this would not be the
show that it is without these movies
it's so true because we're kind of like
film Buffs like obviously we like the
mainstream but we like also Indie more
you know less known we like you know
just films that weren't popular it
should have been that's really what it
is I don't know that they were India I
just think that they were flops
undeservedly so no I actually don't
think I don't think sleepover and she's
the man are considered flop no I'm not
talking about she's a man but Morning
Glory morning glory is not as successful
as it should have been I would say
Country Strong is not as yes big as it
should have been yeah it's so funny like
I often think like if I ever got the
opportunity to interview like Harrison
Ford you know anyone would want to ask
him about Indiana Jones his illustrious
career I would say tell me about your
experience filming Morning Glory from
start to when the script was thrown
across your desk to the cast rap party
just go tell me all about it and then
I'm gonna tell you what that film means
to me and you're gonna listen Harry yeah
Harry
putting together that Harry and Harrison
Ford of the same name yeah he was named
after him
he's a good man to be named no he was
like a good when I was choosing the name
Harrison like he was a Harrison who I
felt really good about being in the same
pool pool is my son yeah that's fair he
I was like oh that it's a strong name if
it's Harrison Ford he's a strong male
lead he's handsome he's a stand-up guy
good role model he's Timeless Timeless
You're Timeless to me I'm thinking the
same thing
what's up friend wait let me think let
me think You're Timeless to me I have no
idea Ted that intro song Ted is on the
list
it's so popular I don't think it's as
popular as it should be I completely
agree and that I think is the impetus
behind a lot of our favorite movies like
they're so good and we just feel so
strongly about them that they should be
as good as we want them to be yeah like
Ted should be like as big as the
hangover
I agree like comedy legend legend like
playing on e-movies we love all the time
I recently watched Ted on the on uh
United they had it and it was such a
delight he is a delight that Ted he's so
cute and you know one of my favorite
stories is that Claudia has met Ted the
inanimate object and Ted the man who
voices him and wrote him that's true yes
I forgot the latter part because I think
the former is more interesting I have
physically held Ted like the 10 that was
there from the movie that was used like
for the CGI yeah was it different than
that other teddy bears I never asked
like was it just a teddy bear no no was
there things inside of him no no I mean
I guess in terms of his chemical makeup
yes it was the same as like if if that
bear were like sitting in Harry's room
would I notice there's anything
different about it definitely the the
bear had a spirit no aside from the
intangible no no no no
it's
really stuffed because like the bear can
technically like stand on its own
oh
you gotta steal it
I completely agree and like when my
actually it's in my my friend's house
and when he showed it to me I was like
the fod and I don't think if he really
showed anyone they would have given a
[__] and I keep expecting like on my
birthday for it to be given to me as a
gift like I don't think it means that
much to him like it means a lot to me
oh my God that would be too cool
too cool too cool yeah I'm too cool to
know you
yeah keep dreaming turdy Lou but I would
love that for you too and would you say
like Ted is bigger than the average bear
yeah like taller
everything because he was not huge he's
kind of the size of a child yes smaller
yeah a small child smaller than Harry
but Harry's big
I don't know
I have I have to do the math
yeah so it's just like an interesting
fact about me that I haven't brought up
in like a couple of months so let me
just remind you she just brought up in
three to four months literally
and then you met the man behind Ted the
genius I did I did lovely fella lovely
fella I actually went to his birthday
party if you read my book you would know
that yeah um it was like a it's a whole
story I wouldn't spoil it because it's
in my book but um and because we've
we've heard it I went as a plus one with
my friend Kade who is the owner of the
bear that's the connection got it yeah
so you're just surrounded by Ted
herstery it's like it's very much like
you know Claudia celebrity Claudia
ashrae celebrity in her circle of
teddies it's really like Claudia
actually celebrity adjacent let's be
real
celebrity plus one hanger honor yeah no
like
silk that's like not an important part
of the story you know like yeah like a
pertinent fact let's go back to the part
where you are in the center of things
yeah yeah you were there you touched Ted
they let you touch him right
of course I did I picked him up oh and I
was like holding like I was giving as
much care and attention like as when I
pick up Harry like it's really like this
is of course a precious being a precious
being that's beautiful steal it next
time for Harry what kind of Aunt are you
for Harry
for Harry for me
well I guess we did dilly dally instead
of diamonds so she did after all now
we're gonna dive in because I want to
get into this fast time stories that you
need to know today and I don't say that
lightly you guys know I actually never
say it so you need to know the fast five
stories that you need to know and she
doesn't say that lightly you actually do
need to know is sponsored by betterhelp
getting to know yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because
we're always growing and changing and
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding because
sometimes we don't know what we want
what we need or why we react the way
that we do until we talk things through
and better help connects you with
licensed therapists who can take you on
that journey of self-discovery from
wherever you are that's the best part of
better help you know your life doesn't
have to stop if you travel you're busy
you can make time for better help you
can make time for therapy because better
help is with you wherever you go it's on
your phone so if you're thinking about
giving therapy a try give better help a
try it's done entirely online and it's
designed to be really convenient really
flexible and suited to your schedule
fill out a brief question engineer to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapists for any time for
no additional charge so the best part of
betterhelp is whenever you're in need of
someone to talk to it is right on your
phone you can chat text video call
regular call so many different ways it's
so accessible and it gets rid of a lot
of like the awkward social interactions
that are involved with therapy like I
don't know leaving your house being in a
waiting room like having to sit across
from someone in person it can be like
kind of awkward I think doing it online
for me at least feels like a way like a
better more freeing situation like I
feel like I can probably be a little bit
more honest
um so to discover your potential today
with better help visit betterhelp.com
toast to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash toast betterhelp.com
t-o-a-s-t
thank you Claudia you're welcome
Jacqueline okay our first story in like
kind of no order of importance okay just
like up and down up and down in no
particular order and I'm just gonna say
Ruthie if you're listening you might
want to just skip ahead right now
Jonah Hill's girlfriend Olivia Millar
unveils a pregnancy bump and Sparks
engagement Rumors by wearing a diamond
ring on her engagement ring finger so um
engaged it appears as though
congratulations are in order for two
time Oscar nominee Jonah Hill and his
girlfriend Olivia Millar on Monday the
actor's latest love interest seemed to
be showing a noticeable baby bum from
while shopping at the real real in
burrow in Santa Monica not this feels
sponsored not far from his 6.7 million
dollar three bedroom Southern Colonial
home which we did do a full analysis on
yes and all the rooms that Ruthie would
have really truly adored
um Jonah and Olivia also our sparking
engagement rumors as she was rocking a
large square cut diamond ring on her
left ring finger while she was looking
pregnant doing errands so Jonah Hill is
expecting and he's unfianced
so you know this is nice you know I'd
love to see somebody settling down
having children it's beautiful
of course the mind wanders to you know
how many children would Ruthie have had
for Jonah Reyna and right by now it
would have been at least three I I think
so it could have been at least three
also we like to report on Jonah's new
girlfriends every time there is a new
one and not to like girlfriend Shaman
because I think he's just been like in
his process of trying to find love but
like yeah he's had a lot of girlfriends
recently and like he kind of has like a
fetish with normies don't you find
normies yes okay so I it was my
understanding that he was still with
that girl I think she was like a nurse
like regular girl Sarah no yeah there
was a Sarah but there was a Gemma uh
Brooke Glazer Aaron galper and Isabelle
McNally and of course Gianna Santos
Gianna not Gemma yeah I knew it was like
an Italian Gianna is the most memorable
one I forget why I think that was the
one that cut the deepest but then he
remember he took that picture with that
blonde girl and he was the happiest he'd
ever been in his whole life Sarah Brady
that was she's a surfer she's a surfer
yes that was like the one after Gianna
so and after Ruthie such a good call he
has a fetish for Normie he's like he's
actually I don't think ever dated
somebody in the spotlight or somebody in
the industry and even though this is
what we advocate for all the time like
people should celebrity should be with
people outside of the industry like it's
just I think both sweater better for her
relationship it's really healthy
there's something like weird about this
yeah no it's like what are you running
from Jonah
so I'm happy though that it seems to be
like
it's this Normie yeah this time right
but what separates this Normie from all
the other normies why now why this
Normie exactly but it is this Normie so
congratulations are definitely in order
and even though I'd rather see Ruthie up
there shaking that shaking that thing
yeah I'm gonna accept this and I'm I'd
rather see Ruthie out there shaking that
rang that's what I said and I'm never
gonna stop fighting for justice for
Rosie like I'm not because it was such
an unjust thing that happened to her I'm
never gonna stop fighting for Ruthie's
rights
and by the way if you're new here which
we I feel like we have so many new
toasters and you don't know what the
[__] we're talking about just ask a
toaster I can't get into it right now
it's honestly too emotionally scarring
and we've explained it on like so many
episodes but it's that's also really
important like thing you need to know a
piece of toast history all right let's
just dive in okay oh to the story
to Ruthie okay yeah to Ruthie I'll do
the Abridged version you'll do the
bridge version okay but I will add color
okay so Ruthie was a toaster we're not
sure if she's still a toaster but this
was back I want to say around
2018. that feels right and what you need
to know about toast culture in 2018 is
that we have never been more toxic like
we had not Claudia and I not Claudia no
no we've always we just had these girls
we just had a fan base that like I don't
know what it was about us that attracted
like the most mentally ill people to our
podcast like we had the like just a
really toxic like like fan base honestly
I don't know what it was I think a lot
of it had to do with this Facebook group
that we started with you know positive
intentions just to like have a community
for all of our listeners to come and
talk about pop culture get advice like
really it was just for anything
um and very slowly I think it was a lot
to do with the culture of Facebook and
like who that attracts
um and just like the Facebook group in
general just like group group Culture
group Culture was toxic so that it's
just important that you know like we
don't really have listeners like that
anymore like listeners are listeners now
we're so you know healthy and balanced
and they're doing really well and I I'm
actually so glad that was a really
conscious Choice Jackie and I made we
were like we have to get out of this
like what are we doing that's attracting
these type of people like we can't so we
really made like a pivot in the last
couple of years and I feel like we've
gotten to such a good place and I'm so
grateful but so just so you know like
what it is now is not what it was during
the Ruthie years okay and I'm not by the
way Ruthie was not one of the best he's
not a bad act Ruthie is the victim here
okay so I just like you needed to know
like the color yeah thank you for that
backstory so it's about 2018 the
Facebook groups for the morning toast
were popping off toasters you know if
you had a celebrity spotting you would
share it in the group like it was really
the group was a cool place to go for
celeb news people would comment on celeb
news so Ruthie was a toaster and she
actually had an IRL quick like meet cute
encounter with Jonah Hill and from and
now that we know he loves Norman it's
not shocking none of this is shocking
and from there she dm'd him was like oh
I just
ran into you on Bleaker and Bleaker
whatever it was and he responded to her
like he Rec he remembered from two
seconds ago when he bumped into her and
he saw her DM and he responded and so
she was so excited and also like unsure
of what to do and how to handle it that
she took it to the Facebook group being
like Oh my God you guys I ran into Jonah
Hill and I messaged him and now we're
dming like what do I say what do I do
she was not sharing it in a nefarious
way she really came to what she thought
was a Sisterhood a safe place for
guidance and it was not a safe space for
Ruthie because while some people were so
excited
and we were all really invested on
Ruthie and Jonah's journey and like
their love story really there always has
to be someone who ruins everything for
everyone and why we can't have nice
things and I can't have Ruthie and Jonah
and one this is why this is you know us
referencing the aforementioned unwell
toasters one toaster screenshotted
Ruthie's posts in the Facebook group DM
them to them to Jonah Hill and said by
the way this girl that you're talking to
is sharing everything in a Facebook
group
here you go
and Jonah was done in that moment and
Joe shut down completely he shut down he
wrote Ruthie off he just like assumed
she was sharing you know in a nefarious
way but it was if she was sharing with
like a group chat you know but but
that's kind of the what the problem was
with the group it's like I'm the one
here oh that's so nice you feel like
it's your group chat but you have to
remember like you don't know these
people and who they're like who lurkers
who lurks in the darkness so so
everything was done with Ruthie all of
their promise their future vanquished
and we've just been left kind of holding
the bag all these years and we never
heard from Ruthie I think she's so
scarred and she stopped listening Ruthie
entered the witness protection program I
wouldn't be surprised if she stopped
listening because honestly like it was
our community that did her wrong and if
she holds it against us again says
honestly I can't blame her no me neither
but it's hard for us now to just like
report on the comings and goings of
Jonah Hill like knowing what we know and
knowing what could have been like Ruthie
was this girl she was Ruthie was the one
for him and it's clear that in all these
years he's been trying to replace the
hole that Ruthie that Ruthie sized hole
in his heart he's been chasing something
that he can't get without were they no
but I think that he's got it now
I hope so I'm really happy for him and a
girl named Olivia is always a fabulous
girl I never met like an ugly loser
named Olivia Olivia's are always just
fabulous I live for you I long for you I
can't talk about how upset I am like I'm
actually in a family with somebody named
Olivia so like it's entirely possible my
name maybe could have been Olivia like
maybe you know for Olivia they ended up
going with something else and then like
oh when I was born oh maybe we'll use
that name we liked Olivia the way that
there are so many songs named Olivia I
could vomit especially by people that I
adore One Direction I live for you along
for you Olivia uh John Mayer I'm
thinking something like Olivia could
keep me through the night or like if I
could have been named Caroline Oh Oh
camera line there's just like no songs
about Claudia
singing Claudia it's Gloria
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's a short looking name Olivia but it
has four syllables even my name
Jacqueline is only three syllables right
and I think that's why it's so good for
songwriting like the syllabic you know
pentameter
works with it I love the syllabic
no it makes me so upset I feel like
I've been to so many John Mayer concerts
where he actually sings Something Like
Olivia and all I'm thinking about is my
[__] sister like I should be thinking
about me at least Olivia is a person
that you love and not like some horrible
my Nemesis and she got all the songs
yeah that's true you know at least it's
not
I'm gonna start I'm not gonna say this
person's name okay
um even though the toasters would have
no idea who I'm talking about oh okay
who's my Nemesis the name starts with an
F
F you gotta go back
yes
[Laughter]
yes my middle school nemesis
yeah that's true at least I'm not
confronted daily yeah in music we're
supposed to be like a place of Solace
I'm confronted by a nemesis that's true
a name that's triggering it can always
be where it's attorney Lou and it's
important to remember that
perspective is everything but you know
who it couldn't be worse for today
Ruthie true Ruthie I don't know where
you are if you're hearing this but if
you are just know we stand with you
we're here for you and you'll get
through this and your story lives on
with us your story lives on with us
someone needs to write a song about
Ruthie it's such a kid and also about
this story like because I feel like the
story has been memorialized because we
never stopped telling it and Jonah Hill
like literally can't fart without us
bringing up Ruthie oh Jonah Hill has a
new movie has Ruthie seen it what is it
weird I was just thinking like about
other songs that like have names like
written by like hot men and so actually
One Direction has another one it's kind
of a weird name
but they're British and it's a big name
oh true princess yeah so why don't you
like step outside the boundaries of your
own culture
there
one thing about me I [__] love being
an American
when I travel abroad I'm even more
certain like I was put on this Earth to
live in America to be an American like I
say this every time I come back like
Diet Coke air conditioning portions
luxuries that we take advantage we take
for granted here in this country
there's another song for you I want to
be in America
by the way literally literally no Born
in the USA that's me
yeah that is you but I just don't feel
like it speaks to your love of like
residing in the USA
yeah but that's why honestly I probably
love country because all country's all
about like land and freedom yeah this
land is your land this land is my land
you know who has the most beautiful
rendition of that song you're not gonna
Sam Hunt Sam Hunt yeah he does
you're gonna have to like forgive him
I want to forgive him and I want to
forget him like you're gonna have to
bury the acts that you have with Sam
Hunt because he's literally so talented
he puts out amazing songs and you're
missing out
hmm
but that's a problem for another day
yeah let's move on to Story number two
one thing at a time okay are you ready
for our next story yeah which is some
serious news because m radus x Sebastian
bear mcclard has been accused of sexual
misconduct in a very large way so
Sebastian bear mcclart is being accused
of sexual misconduct and inappropriate
behavior with teen girls and an
exclusive new report a young woman who
is now 24 claimed in an expose published
by variety on Wednesday that the film
producer reached out to her when she was
just 17 years old via Instagram they
then allegedly met up at a loft in New
York City and the meeting resulted in a
small role in his film good time the
unidentified woman said when she arrived
on set she expected to film with the
movie star Robert Pattinson but instead
she shot a scene in the nude with an
actor who had recently been released
from prison in a statement obtained by
variety that then teen felt utterly
stunned and terrified she said my
distress only worsened when out of
nowhere an actor whispered in my ear if
he could stick it in while the cameras
rolled I said no shortly after the
filming incident the young woman
allegedly began having sex with
Sebastian per variety's report and they
allegedly continued a consensual
relationship for two years I believe at
the legal age of consent in New York is
17 and she was 17.
um aside from that woman's account
another unnamed individual claimed she
met the new york-based filmmaker when
she was 18 and he allegedly began quote
grooming her on Instagram by making
career promises she claimed Sebastian
and I started kissing things escalated
in them without asking Mike for my
consent Sebastian inserted himself
inside me without using a condom the
woman also alleged other Disturbing
Behavior including claims that he called
her the r word and the k word
ah yep and which is the k word the
Jewish one yeah oh my God and we track
her through an app on her phone oh [__]
this woman also alleged that she once
found Sebastian messaging a 15 year old
girl and when confronted he allegedly
appeared police with himself and laughed
at the comment he did not deny any
accusations the second woman's alleged
involvement with Sebastian reportedly
took place while he was already married
to emrata also um so he was a producer
on uncut gems because he was working
with the safety Brothers I always
thought like he was unemployed and I
didn't know that any work that he did
was of note whatsoever
um
but they they cut ties with him there so
they released a statement through a
spokesperson and said the Alara team
were made aware of Sebastian mcclart's
behavior in July 2022 they took
immediate action and terminated him so I
I they had recently found out about this
I think there's like lawsuit ongoing
obviously between emrat and Sebastian
about like their divorce but also
between Sebastian and the safety
Brothers a24 like these production
companies and so all of this is now
coming to light
I mean I it's always the producers the
Randall Emmett it's like these
talentless hacks being a producer is
like a fake job it's not you're not a
director you don't have like a cinematic
eye you're just like a producer you're
like you're a people connector it's like
it's like a job for grifters honestly
yeah and it's always these like salimy
disgusting
talentless hacks who do [__] like this
this is [__] disgusting I literally
hate this man and what what the like ew
yeah I hate him he's been like I've
never heard a really good any good thing
about him even when they were together
it was like he wasn't paying his rent or
something he was like yeah squatting
that was both of them like they were
trying to make a political statement
about like rent
shut up yeah and pay your bills like you
pay your bills uh then it's like he
cheated on emrata while they were
married and now it's like he's grooming
17 18 15 year old girls abusing his
power having like unsigned uh like on
like the 17 year old girl who appeared
in that this short film and by the way
her scene was cut like he found her on
Instagram she doesn't know how the
industry works and that like she doesn't
have to film a nude scene you know or do
anything that would make her
uncomfortable and she doesn't have an
agent or anyone there representing her
so he's like taking advantage of a
vulnerable young people
um and he's [__] disgusting so he's
funny disgusting you yeah oh my God ew
ew
I lit like I hate this man
hate
so that's what's going on with him
that's been going on bye
are you ready for our next story which
is so much needed lighter fare thank you
baby shark's big movie casting has been
announced I didn't know they were making
a baby shark maybe wow that's gonna be a
billion dollar franchise so they're
making a baby shark movie It's called
baby shark's big movie and it's
important to know that baby shark is
already a series on Paramount plus which
I don't know so they already have like
series regulars who play baby shark and
baby shark's best friend and Mommy shark
daddy shark Grandma they Gotta Throw
Some celebs in there of course so those
people from Paramount plus will be
keeping their roles but some big names
have been signed Ashley Tisdale aparna
noncherla ego notum Chloe Feynman and
hyphen and Lance Bass will all lend
their voices to the first ever
feature-length original animated movie
based on the preschool hit the movie
will follow baby shark and his family as
they move to Chomp City the big city of
sharks so cute not only will baby shark
be forced to adjust to life without his
best friend William nearby but he'll
also encounter an evil pop starfish she
plans to steal his gift of song in order
to dominate all underwater music baby
shark has to embark on a mission to
break her spell to restore Harmony to
the Seas so who's the manipulative
Rising pop star Ashley Tisdale stariana
oh my God she literally is being put in
a box again like Sharpay underwater Oh I
actually watched High School Musical
yesterday one and three I heard I was so
in the mood like for just good [__]
music I hear you and that's exactly what
I got that third movie
is unreal
who gave them permission to go so
[__] hard to go so hard so deep it
was so well done so big budget that
opening scene where they're playing the
basketball game and they're like losing
and then they go to the halftime
right now I can hardly breathe oh you
can do it just know that I believe and
he is like so handsome there and she is
so beautiful like they really like are
coming into their own it's so good and
honestly I will never not watch that
final scene and cry I want the rest of
my life to feel just like a high school
music
foreign
also like
Zach and Vanessa are Peak Gardens in
love their Peak relationship in love
like the movie It's it feels like
they're not even acting you know and and
it's like all the problems we had in the
first and second movie like the first
being you know the status quo the second
being Sharpay all those problems
dissolve it's like everyone's friends
Sharpay and Zeke the baker are getting
along it's like all the groups have
melted there's no status quo problem
Sharpay is no longer like the villain to
Troy and Gabriella and they're just
trying to figure out their lives it's
kind of like a relaxing film almost it
is but then it makes you realize like
the big life questions that can get in
the way of high school romance
basketball or drama and it kind of makes
you miss the dumb [__] we used to fight
about the SIM
the Simplicity of Life yeah
yeah it's really stunning and I hope
that baby shark uh it can follow in
their leave in some way big shoes to
fill I will say though I feel like for
these big Blockbuster animated films you
need like a big name
sorry the big name here is that
uh someone who a guest starred on the
Powerman plus series will also be guest
starring in the movie and that is cardi
B and offset oh um who are returning to
reprise their characters Sharky B and
offshark along with their two kids who
voiced
two characters on the
well one of them voiced a character on
the show and then the younger one will
get a role in the movie
so cute yeah you need like a big name
and then like a bunch of like you know
b-listers which it sounded like but the
big name here is baby shark like baby
shark is the name on everyone's lips
baby shark is the song on everyone's
lips so true baby shark
well it's just are you is how are you
gonna see it it's Harry into baby shark
not yet but Kayla is yeah she is so
she'll be seeing his big movie maybe
Auntie quaya could take her I would
literally love nothing more than to take
Michaela to a movie though I'm sure
it'll be on at Paramount plus so you
could just stream oh but then we don't
get to get popcorn and M M's I'll make
it for you I make it because popcorn
okay
cute cute are you ready for our next
story no is it the next story that's
brought to you by bowling Branch it is
because you're not going to be able to
sleep after hearing this you're going to
need bowling Branch wake up feeling
rested and refreshed with the softest
most luxurious sheets from Bowling
Branch Bolin branch is the betting
expert making the highest quality sheets
with Incredible craftsmanship you know
wanted to share a personal anecdote that
happened to me this week I got a text
from my friend Hadley who's a big
toaster and she was like you know what I
finally did it I used kotos at bowling
Branch like I needed a bed of refresh
and she said life equals changed that's
what we do here we change lives it's so
nice when the work that we do like we
get to see it come to fruition you know
I feel like people just use the code and
we never hear from them because they're
sleeping so good you know yeah but
thanks Hadley for reminding me why we do
what we do
Abby could never
Abby could never the signature hem
sheets from Bowling Branch are their
best sellers for a reason because Bolin
branch uses the highest quality 100
organic cotton threads on Earth each set
is slow made for a super Superior
softness and a better night's sleep they
feel buttery to the touch they are super
breathable and they are perfect for both
cooler and warmer weather they're loved
by millions of sleepers their signature
sheets come in 10 different colors and
sizes from twin bed up to California
King they're designed to feel incredible
for all sleepers and they're made
without toxins so they're free from
synthetic pesticides formaldehyde and
other harsh chemicals sleep better at
night with bowl and bread sheets
starting now you can get early access to
their spring sale and use code toast for
20 off today at bowlingbridge.com that's
bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast exclusions apply Seaside for
details bowlingbranch.com promo code
toast thank you Claudia you're welcome
Jackie our next story there's a bit of a
mystery afoot at the U.S treasury
a mystery of foot at the the U.S
treasury so the U.S treasury has
revealed that it received a 7 billion
dollar tax payment in estate and gift
receipts which would mean that Amer an
American billionaire one of the richest
people in America has passed away
without anyone noticing yeah it would
mean that someone with a Fortune of up
to 35 billion dollars has passed away
because there's a few ways that a gift
like this could wind up in the treasury
and some Economist has debunked them all
and come up with the fact that some
billionaire in the world's richest has
passed away well not worlds just America
sorry America well it actually it could
be a non-us citizen who had to pay U.S
taxes but we're the best working theory
is that it was an American billionaire
who passed away seven billion dollars in
estate taxes went to the U.S treasury
and we don't know who it is
so we are looking for a billionaire who
has about what uh 35 billion dollars
okay
yeah based on you know if they were into
uh if they used all the tax laws to
their advantage if they didn't it would
have been someone worth 17.5 billion
no no billionaires know what they're
doing they're not stupid yeah
they're not giving that [__] away okay
all right here's a good kin well not
good can hopefully he's alive but Len
blavatnick and Stephen Schwartzman they
are worth 36 billion dollars and they
made their money from music and
chemicals they were born in Ukraine but
he made a fortune selling his stake in a
Russian Oil Company
um and then purchased Warner Music so
Len blavatnik has a net worth of 36
billion dollars and he's 64 years old
has anyone seen him recently
I don't know another potential is Steven
Schwartzman who is 74
um he only is a philanthropy score of
two while Forbes Associated they give
everyone a philanthropy score
um and he is the son of a dry goods
store owner um and he founded a private
Equity oh he's the founder of Blackstone
wow that would be crazy because the
market is already you know dark Economic
Times ahead yeah so Forbes has a list of
billionaires like who died in 2022 but
it would have meant that they missed
someone
well these two people are still
currently on the list and by the way
they are the only two people because the
list then goes to Michael Dell who has
50 billion dollars which is too much
according to to this so I included it
could be someone with less and who just
like didn't take advantage of all taxes
Jackie billionaires like literally don't
do that there's not a single billionaire
who does wow so I mean because this
Daily Mail article doesn't you know
speculate on who might have died like
they're not as good as dirty oh is that
crazy no no but I think now we need to
get the paparazzi like to I need a
wellness check on Lee blavatnik and
Stephen Schwartzman yeah so the huge
transfer of money was first spotted by
John Rico who's an economist at Wharton
who believed it must have been an error
because I guess like the treasury
Department like just has it listed like
what the money that that's coming in I
mean that's how you know the government
has too much money like they didn't even
realize they got seven bills the
government knew but it like the
government knew
so the government knows who it's from
yeah but that's private government
hiding Secrets a treasury Department
spokesperson confirmed it did not make a
reporting mistake and an IRS spokesman
said that it was unlikely the result of
a backlog which would mean that it was
someone who passed away in 2022 and
wasn't widely reported because a
billionaire one of the richest people in
America dying like would typically be
news
uh I don't know like Lee blavatnik and
Stephen Schwartzman like aren't Super
Famous no but like Forbes there are
people who care about these things yeah
sorry that they're not you know the
Kardashians but they're they're so I
mean Claudia they're Kardashians to
someone it's so true and you know what
they both had amazing careers and I they
both should rest in peace
if it's one of them though it might not
be yeah that's interesting spooky
spookyuki right yeah I mean who knows if
it's like you know a company that's just
like it would be bad for their stock for
them
or just like a deeply private person and
nobody noticed
yeah or like just a really not famous
billionaire
yeah
but even still like when a billionaire
is typically like on the board of
something so then like the board member
there's always you know a thing that
goes out yeah there are really no
untethered billionaires no because then
they wouldn't be billionaires so it
seems a little bit like they're keeping
it on the DL yeah
just something to think about
interesting can't wait to see what they
do with the seven billion dollars
probably a whole lot of [__] nothing
totally
are you ready for our fifth and final
story that's gonna lead into our TV
recap yes Sheena Shea is seen leaving
court at absent Raquel Levis drops
restraining order the interpump rule
Stars Gina Shea was photographed leaving
an LA Courthouse on Wednesday morning
following Raquel's request to drop her
restraining order against her Shea
appeared straightfaced as she walked
alongside her legal team while holding
on to a black umbrella with her right
hand and waiting with her left arm the
goodest gold singer kept her look
Courthouse Chic in a black crew neck uh
with a burnt orange
Blazer and matching trousers this was
truly a sleigh for Miss Sheena Shea it
was TMZ caught her walking out she gave
a statement as she was walking the
umbrella the trench coat the sunglasses
like she really looked so Chic it looked
like Jackie Kennedy Onassis like it was
so stunning and she gave a really she
was very well spoken she was like this
was such an abuse of the court system
there are so many people who actually
need these Services there are so many
people who are actual victims of
violence and who need this kind of
attention this was such a waste of
everyone's time it was just like it was
a it was this [__] sleigh yeah so we
had said last week like Raquel styling
the sharing the restraining order
I'm not allowed to flood my words
that's okay sorry
A2 claudy
Claude Raquel flat filing the
restraining order was a power moved by
her because it kind of shut Sheena out
of the reunion it was a way to get back
at her for whatever transpired between
them but
chess move sheena's coming out on top
today because she's looking good she's
slamming Raquel in her abuse of the
justice system which is just way harsh
Ty and that's really like something yeah
no facts yeah sure and TMZ asked like do
you think you guys could ever get past
this like get back to where you were
Sheena said never literally never the
only critique if I may uh is the phone
change I know by the way I completely
agree like get a purse please yeah like
the phone charm that like is like a
bracelet wristlet no no no like you're
not at the mall with your friends like
please yes you ruin the look a little
bit but still I'm still giving her a 10
out of 10 just because it was like so
unexpected tens across the board yeah
but get a purse
um and so last night's episode of
Vanderpump Rules was like kind of
uneventful um we had her even though
there was like a few things that I found
really interesting that conversation
between Brock Lala and Sheena where they
were just sitting and crying like I was
so like moved by that and I totally see
Brock in a bread new light like the way
I didn't even and I didn't know that him
her and Sheena are really close but the
way that like he's kind of stepped up
and like been there for Lala like I
didn't even think about how she doesn't
have a partner and she is doing this all
on her own I was like like really moved
by that no I know and I've seen a lot on
social media of all of them always
hanging out um and with the kids and
everything like so knowing that they get
together but now knowing like how deep
that runs and how serious it is like
that they've even talked about all
living together which is pretty
unconventional but you know do what you
got to do I thought it was really nice
and also like we were introduced to
Brock and all you know from the jump he
was on the back foot because he has this
domestic violence thing he hasn't seen
his kids in four years like it doesn't
look good for Brock but now knowing all
of that has been squared away and like
that cloud Has Lifted from him I'm
looking at Brock and I'm like what a cat
Sheena and by the way at the reunion he
caught off his ponytail he has like a
buzz cut now and he looks like really
hot the ponytail never even bothered me
but it didn't bother me either he's
always been really good looking but it's
like all this stuff that all this
baggage like it was like oh hey Sheena
but now I'm like look at Sheena great
husband great father yep go Sheena and
to see Lala
acknowledge how like you know she had
all these preconceived notions of Brock
and now she's going through her own
legal battle and she knows it's not just
like what it says on the paper like it's
so much deeper than that to see her like
actually be remorseful and like
introspective and sorry and like
actually like to the point where she
cried that made me have a lot of respect
for her because it feels like in past
episodes like and recently in general
like she's just incapable of like seeing
herself sometimes so I I thought that
was a very good moment for Lala no I
actually do think when Once Lala
understands that she was wrong about
something like she is extremely
humble even in like her relationship
with Katie like all those years all the
terrible things that her and James used
to say like but I guess the difference
here being that like those times were
when she was drinking and like so she
just can group everything together while
she was drinking and it's like I'm sorry
for all of it and this was something
that was like she was completely sober
and maybe she felt like a little
misguided in her
attempts to get Brock to
answer for his sins
um and I did think the whole thing was
really nice and also like when you come
on a reality show like someone's gonna
bring it up skeletons yeah and I'm sure
Lala's just like I just wish it wasn't
me yeah right like she has to live with
that now yeah but it all turned out okay
as Brock said the mother and him are
great and him and Sheena are married and
I'm happy for Sheena and even though
like I have issues with Sheena she
didn't bother me in this episode at all
not at all and you know what she there
was like a few moments where I feel like
she could have
said something like when Tom was like by
the way I'm gonna go to dinner with
Katie tonight instead of the welcome
dinner for sheena's wedding like [__]
no it's my [__] wedding no she was
like No Tonight Tonight everyone's kind
of doing their own thing yeah go and
Christina Kelly is showing up to her
welcome dinner uh I would have literally
lost my [__] she's like Kelly not
embarrassed I know is she embarrassing
it would have been less embarrassing for
her to have room service delivered to
her hotel room we wouldn't have even
like thought where's Christina Kelly
than for her to go Uninvited to sheena's
welcome dinner when all these years you
know sheena's been so beneath her yep
yep yep yep like it was it was a really
bad look for Christina Kelly and for
Lala like why are you bringing her yeah
it's weird how close Sheena is Lala is
with Katie and Sheena she's deeply close
with both of them and it's just
inherently
conflicting no and like literally them
checking into the hotel and like the
whole wedding being in the lobby and
like Katie's it's a bit it's such a this
whole trip is such a bad look for Katie
I don't know what she's doing agreed and
knowing that like she is winding up on
the balcony spying on sheena's wedding
talking [__] like it's such a bad look
it's it's real mean girl energy yeah
um and I feel like now we're at a point
where Raquel and Tom are probably
starting their affair
and to be honest I see no clues like I
don't see them like I don't
know there was nothing in last night's
episode they were barely in the same
conversation or same room she's going a
little bit harder with Tom Schwartz
you really think
do you think that when she made out with
Tom Schwartz she had even made out with
Sandoval yet it's August 2022. is that
when Sheena got married yes I believe so
but but do look at the date because then
Jax had cited Labor Day party as some
where Tom and Raquel were together it's
the end of August right now it's August
23rd that's she's wedding yeah okay now
Google Labor Day 2022.
September 5th so 10 days okay I I still
think I feel like you don't start your
Affair and go to a party like you know
what I mean like you have an affair
you know what I mean yeah or like you
start getting inappropriately close you
go go to a party together when like you
shouldn't and then you start then you
jump into the bed like it's not
you know what I mean like it was maybe
more gradual I have no idea because I'm
not someone who could do something like
this so I really can't conceive of how
it's done
also uh explain to me why Lisa is Lisa
Vanderpump involved in something about
her
no not uh in an official capacity so why
would she know that they got the space
before they know because they're using
Lisa's broker so yeah I know like that
doesn't mean like Lisa has to be on
every call like you give a break and
then explain to me why Lisa thought the
best way to share good news would be you
know sometimes in business things don't
work out and you have to just really
prepare yourself for that so so glad
it's not one of those times you got it
because even though she's having her
Redemptive moments uh she said Lisa and
she likes to I don't know make people
suffer I just thought it was so weird
that she was on that call period and
that she knew the information before
yeah yeah
isn't there like you know real estate
client investor
confidentiality yeah I think it's
probably just really for the storyline
like if the lease has involved in
something about her it's one more thing
for Lisa to be involved in as the cast
moves out of working in the restaurants
right right she's got to stay involved
she has to stay as an advisor to them
and to the Schwartz and sandies and
everything I I can't hear that word one
more time I know it's really bad
it's moronic they just have this space
that they keep
spending money even like the fact that
they said that they bought all the
liquor for Brock and sheena's after
party it's like why
that was like when Tom Sandoval paid for
James's engagement like stop
I have no idea and like I so don't care
about Greg I don't care about this
restaurant it is ugly I don't care about
what's going on the menu like I don't
care yeah I
I just I mean I would care if like there
was something happening but like to
watch like knowing a thousand dollars a
day are being spent like that's
painful yeah why was it so awkward when
Greg's wife showed up
um
why was it so awkward because it was
like a young hot dang I don't know
like you got that too you gotta look out
for that niece but I was stretchen
Gretchen I would say the most butt
clenching moment of the episode oh
goodness gold the less the mob coming
out to goodness and it wasn't even like
a big mob so it was like weird Nobody
Knows the song besides good as gold
except Ariana's real friend because she
actually like knew the melody they like
attacked her with that
it was hard to watch why didn't they
just play the song on a speaker I don't
know or like
it was really hard
no I'm sorry I totally forgot about that
I'm so glad you brought it up thank you
so much no I'm grateful to it was that
I'm grateful to this article because
they called her the good is gold singer
and I actually reminded me I might have
already repressed it from my memory if
they didn't remind me and they were all
kind of like bending their knees and
like squatting like it was like a mob it
was like Gas Stone like and his mom like
attacking her with this song he was like
it was hurtful it felt like they went
weaponized the song the song they needed
pitchforks
what what is that like that
and did they plan to like Shuffle Up
yes and they were all bending their
knees like like a football player like
like Booth 42 yeah it was so
[__] weird and like
it was a lot like it was just a lot
it was so weird I couldn't believe that
like everybody participated in that like
I kind of want to watch it back and like
watch each other you have to watch every
frame yeah to see each person to be to
be like are are they feeling how I feel
I watched both Ariana and Raquel and
Ariana I will say out of all them like
she gave it her all it was clearly her
idea
um and Raquel like was so lost
it was just looking for Lala because I
was like she would never participate in
no she was in there but she was like two
in the mix of people too far into the
mob for me to see her that's probably
for the best for her
it was humiliating
it was
no
just how about a good old-fashioned
surprise surprise yeah
whatever happened to hello
how are you and like you also are trying
to show her that this is a surprise
party like if I saw if I was confronted
with the song like I would think it was
an intervention I would think it was a
flash mob
I don't know I I don't know what I would
think honestly like I would think I need
some new friends
well it was a boring episode but a great
recap so that's all that matters yeah
and at least you know and boring except
for that as we predicted this
was a great episode of the toast as
predicted
that's our show it is our last show of
the week tomorrow there will be a
patreon podcast and video episode
released with Ben and I so if you are
looking for an episode tomorrow make
sure your patreon member because we take
care of everything over there at patreon
we love you guys dearly thanks for a
great week we're back next week and we
hope you have a great day thank you so
much for listening to the toast the
Monday Morning Show where we deliver the
past five stories you need to know
everybody the Friday new jeeps are
watching this on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so on
Spotify
standing in weekly talented we are hope
you guys have a great day and we'll see
you on Monday bye bye